we start tonight with breaking news
about the president fighting back after
two plus years of nothing but complete
and utter cooperation 1.5 million
documents handed over every single
person in the White House encouraged to
cooperate and speak with Muller and
Congress not one time did the Trump
White House invoke executive privilege
not once even White House Counsel which
is to me unfathomable Don Magan spent 30
hours with Muller's Democratic pals and
Hillary's attorney now the president
saying enough is enough and today the
President did finally say enough is
enough by exerting executive privilege
over all aspects of the Mulla report and
the White House ordered former counsel
Don McGann from testifying before
Congress they already have 30 hours the
Attorney General bar is refusing to be
interrogated not by the House Judiciary
Committee by their staff for the 206
years of that committee not one time has
that ever happened and the Attorney
General is saying and it's not going to
happen now and the endless stream of
document subpoenas they are now being
rejected by the administration in other
words the witch hunt is over the
Democrats lost and what the Democrats
are now doing is nothing more than
radical revenge which is born out of a
mass psychotic rage against the
president and by the way four separate
independent fourth they have an
irrational inability to accept four
separate independent results the
nine-month FBI counterintelligence
investigation Oh Peter struck the no
there there
oh we had nothing in just before the
appointment of mullet Lisa paid said we
have the house Intel committee
investigation no collusion no conspiracy
no cooperation with Russia the
bipartisan Senate investigation and now
the 20-month Muller witch-hunt all
determining the same thing no collusion
no obstruction does congress care one
i order how much this is costing and
legal fees and for what what about every
single person that has been called
before the committees or call before
Muller they all have to pay for lawyers
lawyers in Washington DC can be as much
as a thousand dollars an hour now
they're going to be called in to be
asked the same questions that will
fourth fifth and sixth time this is
nothing but harassment and abuse of
power and frankly a brand-new
taxpayer-funded witch-hunt designed to
spear the duly elected president of the
United States and anybody that is there
that dares to enter his orbit in support
that's why tonight we turn to the
Washington swamp 19 term congressman
Jerry Nadler wasting valuable time
resources to continue to prolong and
continue to push a debunked hoax of
conspiracy the desperation reeks in an
effort to be totally transparent the
Attorney General gave Nadler 11 other
senior lawmakers access to a totally
unreadable report that included
everything except grand jury material
everything both 0.1% was handed over
because that's illegal got to keep in
mind this is because of a law that
Nadler supported in the 1990s Barr was
under no obligation because people like
Nadler wanted the law this way he didn't
even want the Starr report sent to the
American people to be seen by the
American people was fighting against we
the people seeing that then they changed
the law now the Attorney General has no
obligation to release one word of the
Moller report but still the Attorney
General bar well unredacted classified
information ongoing case materials other
publicly withheld content that might
reveal sources and methods the whole
entire country was able to see the
Judiciary Chairman Nadler and his fellow
Democrats all refused to actually take
the time and see the unredacted version
go see the whole thing instead today
chairman Nadler circus
voted to hold the Attorney General in
contempt of Congress and according to
Nadler this is all about Boras decision
to defy his subpoena which demanded that
the Unruh tracted Muller report be
released to the full committee ranking
committee member Doug Collins will join
us in a moment pointed out that Nadler
once claimed that a subpoena was quote a
powerful and coercive tool only to be
used when attempts to reach an
accommodation with the witness have
reached an impasse but during the
hearing chairman Nadler on his high
horse in his circus committee while he
said the subpoena was merely intended to
start a dialogue with Parrs office oh
that's new let's start a dialogue here
we're gonna subpoena you and we'll have
other members threaten the sergeant of
arms to put you in cuffs and drag you to
the committee take a look the subpoena
is written as the beginning of a
dialogue process is it with any of a
process to talk to the Attorney General
and to the Department of Justice and
ultimately to go to court but it's
designed to be the foundation of a
dialogue and is not designed to force
our hand in what we insist on in court
this is not the first time that Nadler
and his circus had been caught totally
completely utterly contradicting himself
as it turns out Nadler has one set of
standards for his good friend could Oh
Bill Clinton Bill Clinton the Starr
report listed eleven separate felonies
committed by Clinton he lost his
practice as what licensed to practice
law he did pay Paula Jones almost a
million dollars and yeah he was
impeached yet Nadler has a whole other
standard for President Trump so you know
just like Democrats care about collusion
but not if it's Ukraine and Hillary they
care about obstruction but not Hillary
and her deleting subpoenaed emails
33,000 bleach bid and hammers and SIM
cards removed they don't care about that
they care about
I believe but only for a high school
student Kavanagh not for the lieutenant
governor of the Commonwealth of Virginia
selectively moral outrage anyway watch
it is the culmination of nearly three
months of requests discussions and
negotiations with the Department of
Justice for the complete unredacted
report by special counsel Muller
somebody the staff of the Judiciary
Committee perhaps the the chairman and
ranking minority members of the
Judiciary Committee is going to have to
go over this material at least the four
or five hundred pages in the report to
determine what is fit for release and
what is as a matter of decency and
protecting people's privacy rights
people who may be totally innocent third
parties
what must not be released at all do you
think the president of structure justice
yes I do it's very clear that the
president struck the justice we must not
overturn an election and remove a
president from office except to defend
our system of government or our
constitutional liberties against the
dire threat we have to protect the rule
of law and that means we have to
investigate and hold hearings and lay
out for the American people if the
administration is involved in abuse of
power abuses of power or obstruction of
justice the American people have heard
the allegations against the President
and they overwhelmingly oppose
impeaching him they elected President
Clinton they still support him we have
no right to overturn the considered
judgment of the American people just a
phony hypocrite and by the way is
shifted opinion is not just an exercise
an anti-trump vitriol and hypocrisy
nanners current fishing expedition is
about so much more than a simple case of
Trump hate rage derangement syndrome
Democrats now fear of the Attorney
General caught red-handed concocting
perpetuating a massive fraud this is
what's underlying the fear and the
hatred and the attacks against the
Attorney General the Attorney General
will expose their hopes their conspiracy
theories what really happened it scares
the living daylights out of them because
he's going to investigate the biggest
abuse of power and that's only just
beginning so they got to smear him
before he does his job